we are feeling Jennifer's new movie
hustlaz because trust me when I tell you
these ladies aren't afraid to put it all
out there I would think we should get
this for your consideration campaign
going it's just a fun sexy kind of
dangerous yes world what I like to think
I was on kind of a Robin Hood s journey
before they're stealing from the rich
and to give them to themselves what I
love about it is Lorraine our director
did is she made sure that like there are
women of all types all shapes and sizes
all different like backgrounds and
that's what I love about it because it's
really like body-positive and that's the
epic ensemble includes singer Liz Oh
whose music has become anthems for body
acceptance it is a really cool movie to
be a part of I'm like damn this is a big
deal like everybody's talking about this
damn movie and I'm just so happy to have
a small part the small part that I have
in Hustler's JLo's character teaches
Constance how to work a pole you're
gonna do that behind the scenes JLo and
the ladies learned how to master the
craft from this woman
the film's official consultant and pro
her name Jack the stripper I really
appreciate it a JLo was like Jack how
can I make this more authentic scissors
Liz Oh had moves we already know this
but she was up there having a really
good time being super confident you know
diamond from the Bronx right so baby
there were a lot of real strippers on
set so they didn't need much help you
know cardi knew how to I didn't need to
teach her anything
thank you it's all easy to do noise you
can't do it at home no you can't do it
at all
alright I'm gonna take my cues from car
to keep my feet on the ground go stick
it with Guardi she is giving major props
to her hustlers co-star Liz Oh on her
first number-one record on the Billboard
Hot 100 with truth hurts my jam cardis
first solo hit you know bode acts yellow
also reached number one she tweeted
quote the fact that Liz Oh a couple
months ago felt underestimated take that
take that makes me emotional I love it
women supporting women
[Applause]
[Music]